well tourism is certainly picking up
across the valley and that's stimulating
our economy jeremy j ford spoke to a
unlv professor to find out how those out
of town dollars are still needed
each day thousands of travelers make
their way through las vegas either
flying via harry reid international or
driving in from neighboring states las
vegas as it has been for a long time is
still a great place to visit there's a
lot of stuff to do here
and people are still really attracted to
vegas as a tourist destination
david g schwartz is a gaming historian
at unlv he tells me we've still got a
long way to go before we reach
pre-pandemic visitor numbers well
obviously with the pandemic there's a
lot less travel people wouldn't come to
las vegas because they couldn't do a lot
of things they wanted to do now a lot of
those restrictions have gone away but we
still have things like high fuel prices
and inflation to deal with which might
cause for some travelers to simply just
stay at home yet some industries in town
are thriving for gaming things are
getting a lot better the gaming revenues
continue to be at record highs we're
seeing the non-gaming pickup
entertainment is starting to come back
so i think the next piece would be
convention as we all wait for things to
be back to normal again i think the most
important thing is that las vegas
economy really is part of the global
economy and we're affected by what
happens around the world jeremy j ford
live local now